what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the marvel cinematic
universe today we have two really big
pieces of new information about
spider-man no way home one is a scene
involving tobey maguire tom holland and
andrew garfield we have seen leaked
photos of this scene before even a
leaked video but now we have some
dialogue to go along with it and the
dialogue is very clear so of course i'll
be breaking that down but also we have
some new information about a very
specific scene from spider-man no way
home as well some new things have come
to light about a certain scene and with
4k trailers we're able to see a little
bit more than we were before and it
looks like we could have been really
wrong about one of the members of the
sinister six but this is probably a good
mistake on our part because you're
probably going to like who the villain
actually is instead if these rumors are
true and if you're new and this news
interests you consider subscribing and
hitting that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so we'll first start off with
this new audio that we got in the scene
that is known now as the cot and 4k
scene we had the leaked photo of andrew
garfield come out a lot of people said
it was fake andrew garfield said it was
fake and then we got a 4k hd video of
the actual scene proving that it was
indeed real unfortunately with this
video we did not get any audio it was
just video however if you paid close
attention and tried to read andrew
garfield's lips it did look like he was
saying something like so you have like
web blood if this is correct this is
obviously him talking to toby maguire
spider-man who does not have web
shooters but produces them organically
well now we have audio that kind of does
prove that this is what he's saying
because the audio is now coming from
toby maguire now i want to add that we
are not sure if this is 100 real or if
it's fake it does appear to be real but
a lot of people are trolling right now
so take this with a grain of salt it's
not 100 confirmed to be a real leak
however it does kind of seem like it is
now we have two different audio clips
which i believe are actually from
different scenes or at least different
sentences but we have two nonetheless if
these are legitimate i unfortunately
cannot put them on here however if you
go to my twitter i quote tweeted a link
to this audio with the title real or
fake so simply go to my twitter and you
can hear it my twitter handle is at
cosmic wonder yt and you can find that
in the description and the pin comment
the first one is him saying on my world
octavius died now we obviously know what
this is about in spider-man 2 doc ock
died at the end and he did have a
redemption at the end which i'm curious
to see how that plays out in spider-man
no way home because he sacrificed
himself but he was sacrificing himself
to save everybody from what he created
so you know but he had a change of heart
nonetheless at the end and he redeemed
himself so now in spiderman no way home
it looks like that's all gone out the
window but from this line it's very
clear that tobey maguire spider-man has
seen dog ock and he is telling the other
spider-man that in his world doc ock
died now we actually know how doc got
comes back we know because director john
watts told alfred molina and alfred
molina told the world in an interview
alfred molina himself was wondering how
he was going to come back when he died
in the last film and john watts told him
that in this universe nobody ever really
dies and that they were going to pick up
his character from that final scene in
spider-man 2. so there is a chance that
he gets taken from the water before he
actually does die because obviously we
have seen him in the trailer and he
recognizes peter now he could be a
variant but i'm still going to assume
that he's from toby maguire's universe
now the other set of audio goes with
what we believe andrew garfield was
saying in that leaked video in this one
toby mcguire says you both have web
shooters now if this audio leak does
indeed end up to be real this obviously
would be a part of the same conversation
in which andrew garfield what we believe
him to be saying says so you have like
web blood if these leaks are true this
obviously means that the three
spider-man are going to have a
conversation about the obvious and that
is that two of the spider-man andrew
garfield and tom holland have web
shooters but toby mcguire produces his
webs from his arms organically as most
people know they come out of his wrist
and if you haven't seen the first three
original spider-man films i highly
suggest you do that before spider-man no
way home comes out if this happens this
is truly great because that means
they're going to acknowledge those
little details that we want them to
acknowledge technically these spider-men
the three of them are going to be
variants of each other and it would be
very cool if they noticed the
differences that each of them have the
web shooters being one of them i'm also
really curious to find out about the
relationships that they've had in their
own universes as we know tom holland
spider-man had a really great
relationship with iron man so i'm
curious as to if the other two
spider-man went on to have a
relationship with any of the other
avengers regardless i can't wait to see
all three spider-man on screen if
everything ends up being real which i
truly do think it's going to be real we
will see them all on screen and
hopefully it's just going to be an
extremely fun time now as i mentioned we
have another scene to talk about and
that scene is from the spider-man no way
home trailer when we see tom holland get
attacked by something from behind we
have a lot more details about this scene
now we originally thought that this was
the lizard but when we look at this in
4k i'm not so sure anymore it doesn't
seem like this person has a tail in fact
this actually kind of looks like venom
now let's not start any venom is
confirmed for spider-man no way home
rumors because we still don't get a
crystal clear look at this but to me it
really does seem like we can't see a
tail here now some people have said it's
the hulk i definitely do not think it's
the hulk some people have said that it's
abomination because of what we saw in
shanghai but i don't see any like spikes
around his neck or anything like that so
i don't think it's him either so i'm
definitely thinking it's either venom or
the lizard and again i don't see a tail
and if you saw the venom post credit
scene anything's possible now and that's
all i'll say about that however it's
very clear here that this creature will
say goes to attack peter but hits a
magical barrier we have heard that
doctor strange is going to keep these
multiversal villains in some type of
prison and it looks like that is exactly
what we are seeing here it looks like
peter is at the sanctum and it looks
like he is looking at all of the
multiversal villains that doctor strange
has captured now according to an
accurate plot leak from here peter kind
of disagrees with doctor strange about
keeping the villains prisoners and
sending them back to their own universes
because if that happens they will die
since they are taken from the point of
right before they die doc ock taken from
the water right before he drowns the
green goblin taken probably before his
glider runs into him and so on and so
forth and if you take a look at the
background of this it does look like the
background of a scene that we saw in the
trailer the room in which strange does
his spell it looks like there are rooms
in the background and one of these rooms
looks like the room that either the
lizard or venom is in so it looks like
the spell causes the multiverse to break
and some of the villains come into the
sanctum in which dr strange then
imprisons them so it looks like that is
the scene that we are seeing here either
the lizard or venom in a prison a
magical prison that doctor strange has
put him in this means that the others
will be put in prisons as well and the
plot leak is most likely true where
peter and doctor strange kind of fight
and the result is the villains get let
out of these prisons leave the sanctum
and then start to terrorize new york
which obviously they have to get out
because they're the bad guys they can't
be in prisons the whole time so be sure
to let me know what you think about this
and be sure to let me know what you
would like the three spider-man to talk
about when they finally get together on
screen don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
uh
[Music]
you